I thought this was pretty fascinating
Florida Governor defends migrant flights
to Martha's Vineyard suggests more to
come so here's what happened is uh
DeSantis
who is a governor in Florida
and I always think it's interesting how
like if somebody there's a problem
somewhere people don't know about it
elsewhere but they'll have an idea about
it they'll be like oh well this is what
they should do this is what they should
do but you until it's right there with
you then it then suddenly it's you get a
real concept of what the issues are
so that's why I think this is pretty
fascinating I mean it's definitely a
little bit a little bit gangster to be
using humans and shifting them around
um
but
it's interesting now that it's suddenly
a Martha's Vineyard you just imagined us
you know 50 low-key just locked out
[ __ ] uh
uh visitors just hanging out that's the
part to me that see because I love
anything that bothers [ __ ] rich
people I love that [ __ ]
if you could bother the rich man if you
could [ __ ] tickle the rich with dirty
fingernails [ __ ] I love that [ __ ]
so I think anytime you can drop off a
couple of essays
um up in Martha's Vineyard baby let's do
it that's what I'm saying
you know you got MS-13 suddenly you got
mv13 baby you got Martha's Vineyard 13.
baby
you know that's when shit's gonna get
weird
so yeah I just because then people get
to see what what issues are like
um we had a border patrol agent on here
at one point I remember
and he was in charge of the Arizona
border
uh
for a long time
I can't remember how long maybe 17 years
and he was saying one of the biggest
problems on the border was that people
were coming over good people and bad
people
were coming over and they weren't
prosecuted like even if they arrested
the people like two weeks later they
were coming right back because there was
no like legislation happening where they
were actually like the executive branch
wasn't Prosecuting them
and you don't until you talk to somebody
who's from there you don't really have a
good idea of what's going on
um so that's why I like this I wish
there was like buses of different
problems from different areas that were
just kind of cruising around the country
and they dropped somebody else's problem
off in your area for a while and then
they take your problems and drop them
off of an air then they take um
you know like in Maine maybe they got
beached whales or something miss you and
then they dropped them [ __ ] off in
Idaho and they're like damn bro you know
and and I just think it would be
interesting if different buses were just
just like oh [ __ ] here come this [ __ ]
trouble bus and you see whose problem it
is today you know like damn
they got uh
you know
um like women aren't shaving under their
arms in Oregon or whatever or in like
you know somewhere and then them [ __ ]
get out you're like dang bro I didn't
know it was like that
so I think it would be interesting if
there was a whole system of this going
on
so that's something that I think I would
like to see in the future is just like a
whole kind of uh
different issues from different areas
kind of cruising around that way
everybody could get a little bit of a
taste
and see because then when you vote on a
national level and you have an idea of
your whole country
you get like a real idea
of
what real of what people's issues are
you know and for me a lot of that stands
people talk about racism all the time
and um
and they're like what you know I'll hear
people like in California talk about
like the South uh but they've they've
they're not they didn't they didn't grow
up in the South they don't understand
some of the intricacies and like the
boots on the ground
um every day
uh
uh existence of living in a place that's
had a lot of racism
um or black and white racism maybe and
so I think sometimes that's crazy to me
it's like well but you don't know you
don't live you don't have to understand
you know you may have like a vision of
it
and information but until you get that
understanding so I like that man maybe
this is some understanding buses that's
not it it's not like a problem bus it's
like okay here comes some understanding
buses we're about to understand this
[ __ ] you know and then it drops off and
it's like a surprise you're like oh [ __ ]
man
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one